so I don't know how many of the millions
of cybertruck pre-orders are from Europe
but there's a certain set of rules that
might make those orders impossible to
fill see it's not how sharp the truck is
it's not the visibility the main rule is
that the front of a vehicle cannot be
stiff which sounds weird like isn't
every vehicle somewhat stiff but the
panels of other vehicles are actually a
pretty thin metal which dents and
crumples fairly easily which can be kind
of annoying if you just hit like a
little rock or whatever and it dents
your hood but it's much more safe when
that's a human head now the cyber truck
on the other hand well all these panels
are infamously made of stainless steel
which is awesome for durability like
this thing's going to be impossible to
dent and scratch and they're even going
around telling people it's bulletproof
to a degree that means if it hits a
cyclist or pedestrian it's not going to
crumple or dent in a way that actually
softens the blow for impact and makes it
more safe so that Elon quote that if
you're ever in an argument with another
car you'll win is probably true but the
whole bumper must be able to absorb
energy to protect pedestrians rule in
Europe is not going away anytime soon